[Music]
Mario who has been fired from his job as
an executive recruiter was spotted at
the gym one source tells us that Corinne
and de Mario were shown the video of
their naked pool encounter while they
were still in Mexico another source says
Corinne who is seeking therapy actually
had a boyfriend when she signed on to
paradise she was quote not planning on
hooking up with anyone she wanted to
hang out stir up drama and just have fun
but it's that same attitude that got
Corinne into trouble in the past do you
feel that you were [ __ ] shamed by the
other women maybe I was a little bit
[ __ ] shamed but I will admit I did look
a little bit more promiscuous than I
thought it would but I'm sorry I don't
know I'm human I just thought it was
cute and funny with both contestants
lawyered up what's next a source tells
us Demario feels like the scapegoat in
the situation and that he feels race is
an issue the priority is to get the
tapes and to preserve all evidence
[Music]
you